every so often the foundation gets a tip
off about an anomalous object rather
than discovering it through their global
surveillance network tip-offs aren't
common because few people know how to
even get in contact with the foundation
directly but when they do it's always a
relief the agents and mobile task forces
that are sent to investigate and
retrieve possible scps usually walk in
blind there's no telling what they might
find but when a tip-off report or
informant from one of the groups of
interest comes in and spills the beans
the brave front-liners of the foundation
usually have a slightly better idea of
what they're tackling
usually sometimes they get complacent
and end up underestimating or going in
unprepared and when that happens well
the consequences can be disastrous
way back in 1990 the foundation received
an unexpected tip-off from some of its
contacts based on the island of hong
kong it wasn't much just a location and
a general description of the effects
told discreetly over the phone the
contact was one of some 50 000 chinese
residents of a particular neighborhood
in hong kong the infamous kowloon walled
city the city was originally a chinese
military fort on the island of hong kong
when the island was sold to the british
empire at the end of the 19th century
the fort was converted into massive
densely packed apartment buildings and
quickly became an enclave for the
chinese when japan occupied hong kong
during world war ii tens of thousands of
ethnic chinese on the island took refuge
in the massive apartment blocks of the
slum there was no government no police
no laws the dozens of floors were
controlled by gangs and drug dealers but
it was better than being homeless and of
course the residents were incredibly
suspicious of any authorities you can
imagine why the foundation was reticent
to send some of their best men into a
densely packed civilian area that was
likely to be hostile to their presence
their contact informed them that the
anomalous object was a small relic of
some kind with strange terrifying powers
it was located deep in the heart of the
walled city and it might even be
responsible for the very city's
existence foundation command considered
that the alternative was letting 50 000
people reside inside of an uncontained
anomaly and decided they'd send someone
to investigate they picked troops from
mobile task force zeta 9 the mole rats
the mole rats are some of the
foundation's most trustworthy operatives
they're a task force specially trained
and equipped to operate in dangerous and
anomalous environments particularly
those that are underground or underwater
whether it's an undersea cave system or
an endless claustrophobic basement the
mole rats perform search rescue
containment and even recovery in these
terrifying places they seem like the
natural fit to be the ones to lead the
expedition while exploring and finding
out what in the world had caused the
kowloon walled city the team landed in
hong kong on june 3rd led by one gordon
richards a member of zeta9 he kept an
extensive personal diary as most asians
do and from it the foundation was able
to learn what
scp-184 truly was the first impression
richards had of the walled city while
exploring it with his partner henry was
pure disgust it was a densely packed
slum that was largely made of trash and
refuse covered in filth and stinking too
high heaven the suits that the team wore
protected them from any hazardous
material or danger but it was still a
vile experience moving through the
cramped streets and corridors of the
ghetto at one point richard's partner
was walking through an area piled
knee-deep in trash when the floor gave
out dumping him into a cesspool on their
first day they learned practically
nothing from the locals the residents of
the walled city were suspicious of
outsiders they'd either avoid the agents
or throw trash and insults at them from
afar in cantonese and sometimes mandarin
but richards did manage to catch
whispers in some of the bars that
peppered the city there was something
strange in the center of the mass
something that sounded nothing short of
anomalous foundation agents assisted
hong kong police officers in conducting
raids overnight hoping to find more
information in the morning the molerats
returned to investigate and found the
first evidence of something actually
anomalous affecting several of the tiny
apartments from the outside they looked
like the same ragged shanties as the
other hundred square foot apartments but
they were far too big from the inside
henry had seen spooked since his fall
into the cesspit the day prior the other
agents tried talking to him but it
didn't help much and he spent most of
the day in a strange fugue muttering to
himself richards told him to knock it
off but never reported it feeling bad
for the new kid the next day would be
spent in the sewers trying to find a
direct route to the center of the city
where the object was being held richards
went into the sewer with a fellow agent
but found nothing except more waste and
filth they were unable to get on the
radio with the rest of the team inside
the actual building until they came out
early the next day after spending almost
a full day underground they were quickly
pulled out by other agents and briefed
while they had been in the sewers henry
and another agent had been exploring the
central portion of the city that's when
they were rushed by an angry mob dozens
of people attacked before they even had
a chance to retaliate both were
viciously beaten but henry was dragged
off deeper into the city and the other
agent was injured during his retreat
back to base when they could no longer
hear henry's screams on the radio
several armed agents rushed in to
extract him that's when they heard
henry's radio again he was screaming and
rambling incoherently sounding like he
was hallucinating about the city being
alive when the radio cut out again the
search team was shocked by the sight of
henry rounding the corner running at
full pace and screaming without his
helmet he pushed an agent aside before
smashing right through one of the weak
thin garbage walls falling six stories
onto a pile of metal scrap the site was
gruesome and it took them hours to
recover his body zeta 9 was done
screwing around they were going to round
up the city's leaders and find this
anomaly before it killed anyone else
over the next day or so the agents aided
by the hong kong police department
rounded up many of the city's elders and
community leaders pulling them from
their apartments and shanties zeta9
worked on interrogating them for
information while richards provided the
muscle the first person they pulled was
a member of the chinese triads one of
the gangs that functionally ran the city
when he didn't cooperate the agents
broke his legs and he suddenly became a
lot more talkative he explained that the
anomaly was called the builder and no
one quite knew where it came from or how
it worked the closest he had ever come
was standing guard outside rooms while
it worked and that the city elders would
know more when he brushed off henry's
death richards broke his jaw the next
person was an ancient looking chinese
man named long wen one of the city's
reclusive elders he was indomitable no
matter what richards did he wouldn't
give in under abuse or torture but when
one of the agents suggested that zeta9
pay a visit to his family he immediately
opened up he told them that the builder
was kept in an old temple that the city
had grown around it was highly secret
and only a few people could look upon it
without going mad he had tried to show
henry so that the foundation wouldn't
take it away but obviously that hadn't
gone quite as planned when asked where
it was long when explained that as soon
as the agents had arrived they had moved
it deep inside the city where no one
would be able to get to it but zeta9
took that as a challenge tomorrow they
were moving into the city's temple and
not coming out without that anomaly
richards and the rest of the mole rats
prepared themselves for the expedition
over the following few days they were
going to venture deep into the heart of
the kowloon walled city far away from
any supply lines or external foundation
support they made sure they went in
heavily armed with their suits life
support enabled and prepared for every
possibility they departed on june 8
heading straight into the belly of the
city where henry had been abducted by
the mob at first it seemed strange but
not overtly anomalous the same dingy
damp apartments full of garbage but
eventually they came upon what they were
looking for a small tiny temple buddhist
in style and design it was made out of
stone and wood with a small buddha
statue out front it was the only thing
that looked remotely out of place
otherwise surrounded by shanties and
cobbled together homes in the words of
the great david brin
this must be the place at first it was
nothing new the temple was too big on
the inside but it was nothing they
hadn't seen in the hundred other rooms
in this massive building a small shrine
a few seats here and there altars but
then richards and the other agents
noticed something a sliding door built
into the wall of the tiny 10-foot temple
it made no sense a door would exit out
into the apartment right next door when
they opened it they found
a hallway leading deeper into the
structure made of the same wood and rice
paper that the temple was constructed
from it was long too at this point they
should have been deep into the other
apartments in the building more so than
any other room they had checked before
as they traveled down the corridor they
found more sliding doors lining the
walls more temple rooms altars and
meditation chambers all recreated and
rearranged by the anomaly it was like
someone built 12 whole temples inside
this one tiny structure expanding ever
inward
that must have been why they called this
thing the builder whatever it was the
molerats knew that this place was bound
to be gigantic and set up a small base
camp in the original temple to stop any
of the residents from getting the jump
on them then they got their suits sealed
their equipment rigged up and went to
work exploring the various corridors
hallways and temples that had grown out
of this anomaly at first it was simple
and repetitive but things started to get
strange after the sixth hour of
exploration the rooms began to thin out
until the molerats were mostly exploring
uninterrupted long hallways made out of
bamboo and rice paper they came upon a
room with something inside it another
meditation chamber but this time a small
bronze buddha statue was placed in the
center of the room it was the size of
richard's fist and his team collected a
sample before moving to the sliding door
at the rear of the room they opened it
up and exited right back into a
meditation room with a tiny fist-sized
buddha in the center for a second they
thought they had been transported
backward but this buddha didn't have any
samples taken out of it it was an
identical copy of the room they had just
entered through strange but not
unexpected they didn't bother taking a
sample and move to the next room which
was also a meditation chamber with a
buddha in the middle all in all they
found 83 rooms in a row that were
identical copies of that one chamber
with the buddha connected by the sliding
doors after that experience and a few
hallways later they came upon another
familiar sight a perfect recreation of
the original altar room they had entered
into the temple from but with one
difference rather than being made out of
planks of wood and stone this room
seemed to be carved from a single
massive piece of wood with no seams or
breaks there were no tool marks anywhere
and it looked as though it had been
somehow naturally formed but they did
find a small collection of documents
written in chinese in the corner they
scanned the documents and sent digital
copies back to hq the agents at the base
responded the anomaly had been
designated scp-184
and the temple goers seemed to think it
was a gift from god they allowed people
to bring it into their apartments for a
small payment and let it grow the space
zeta9 resolved to grab it and get out
before it could expand the temple any
further they bunked down for the night
to get some sleep the next morning they
continued moving through the temple
until they hit a branch in the road and
split the team richards picked one
hallway and set out on his own climbing
upwards the walls in this section of the
temple were irregular they were
undulating wavy the wood and rice had
given way to hard stone hallways richard
slipped into one of the rooms to rest
for a while and found that all the
furniture was made of beautiful green
jade despite being wonderfully soft he
rested on the jade bed for a while
before continuing on he wrote in the
journal that he didn't feel well
disconnected from the environment not
like a usual mission one of his team
members had died and the environment
itself felt hostile without anyone else
to talk to he was thinking too much but
it was just nerves he signed the journal
and kept moving for the next hours and
days richards continued on his suit's
ability to make food and water was
running low as he moved to the stone
temple he saw something out of the
corner of his eye that wasn't there when
he looked again he heard voices that
couldn't possibly be there he'd been
climbing for so long he'd lost track of
time while climbing up the shaft he
finally saw light and darted through
only to enter a room filled with lit
candles not sunlight enraged he smashed
them all with his helmet breaking the
helmet to pieces he sat and cried for a
while before dropping something down the
shaft to see how far it was to the
bottom but never heard it hit the floor
he set his jaw screw containment he had
to find this thing and utterly destroy
it the next time he saw something it was
days later his food and water had run
out when he had found a hall filled with
doors lining every surface they all led
back into the wall but he noticed he was
bleeding the floor wasn't carpet but
razor-sharp stone pinpricks that had
shredded the boots of his suit to
ribbons along with his feet he returned
to climbing after patching himself up a
little he had to kill this thing somehow
the rest of the entries are disparate
and unsigned one of the rare coherent
ones revealed that he was at the top of
the shaft had something called the hall
to forever filled with light and that he
was going to kill the heart
around the time these entries were
written the other members of zeta9 felt
the temple shaking and cracking growing
unstable they quickly evacuated minutes
before they saw the interior of the
temple collapsing in on itself the
entire expanded area collapsed into the
tiny space of the original altar room
through the rubble the members of zeta9
found richard's journal along with a
tiny metal object matching the
descriptions of
scp-184 they never did find richard's
body he went missing during the recovery
presumed killed in action after it was
brought back to base foundation
researchers went to work on it it was a
tiny metal statuette in the shape of a
dodecahedron the metal it was made from
was unknown but tests revealed that it
was magnetic and hard as brass
experiments followed they discovered
that when they put scp-184
inside an enclosed structure like a room
or building or even a cardboard box it
would expand the interior dimensions
without making it grow larger the effect
was powerful the rooms it was tested in
would grow by hundreds of square meters
every day at first it just moves the
walls out making the room up to three
times bigger than it is but after that
it gets strange during a test in the
small bedroom in a suburban home after
it grew the room three times in floor
space it began to create entirely new
rooms the researchers suddenly went in
to find three kitchens six bedrooms a
dozen bathrooms and tens of closets they
were all fully furnished
scp-184 was capable of copying materials
from the rest of the building but not
particularly well the appliances in the
kitchen were made of wood or rock and
the furniture was limited to glass sofas
and chairs the rooms were oddly shaped
as the house went on at first they were
oval but the deeper bedrooms were
pentagonal and even star-shaped they
even found one bedroom that was a
perfect sphere some of the doors led
right into an empty wall and the
hallways changed in size and shape and
led around into themselves like a
labyrinth the researchers quickly
removed scp-184 from the house and tried
to figure out how to contain this thing
if there's one thing the foundation is
good at it's locking things up in boxes
but locking this thing up in a box is
the most dangerous thing they could
possibly do one researcher had an out of
the box idea
scp-184 was placed between two
electromagnets which kept it floating in
mid-air and made it impossible to pull
away that solved half the problem and
the foundation knew exactly where to put
it without enclosing it in a space only
a few years after the events of zeta9's
recovery the hong kong government
finally demolished the massive kowloon
walled city replacing it with an open
park commemorating the site with many
statuaries and relics from the city the
foundation made sure they were able to
install
scp-184's electromagnets as another
statuary inside a gazebo finally
containing
scp-184 right where it had been all
along be it ever so humble there's no
place like eternally recursive home now
go check out
scp-3008 trapped in ikea and
scp-2427 a thing full of stuff for more
anomalous locations you might never
escape